welcome to the Intriguing world of
default gateways the pivotal Junctions
in the network communication landscape
envision your home router not just as a
device but as a digital Navigator
directing each online action you take
from sending an email to streaming media
through the complex web of the internet
this Gateway acts as your primary
conduit to the Digital Universe
definitely handling the traffic between
your local network and the vast expanse
of the global internet in broader
networks like those in corporate or
academic settings the role of the
default gateway expands
here it's a traffic conductor ensuring
smooth internet data flow and secure
access to external resources consider
smart home devices all reliant on this
gateway to reach out to the world for
updates and synchronization even in a
bustling CAF Wi-Fi network the default
gateway is what allows your device to
step into the online World am miss a sea
of digital requests diving into the
default gateways realm is more than a
technical foray it's an exploration of
the invisible yet critical force that
binds the digital experiences it's a
journey through the heart of network
communication revealing the essential
role these gateways play in keeping our
world connected and efficient let's
delve into the essential aspect of
networking a Cornerstone that keeps our
digital lives running seamlessly and
before commencing just a quick info for
you if you're are an aspiring cyber
security professional looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learn postgraduate program
in cyber security from Mi University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
a right choice through this course you
will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen others if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then check out the link in
the pin comment and description box
below so without any further Ado let's
get started so let's start with the
simple definition of default gateway so
a default gateway in networking is
analogous to a doorkeeper or guide in a
vast comple comp Lex of buildings it
serves as the primary access point data
device in a network uses to interact
with devices in other networks so we
talk about the technical definition it's
a note often a router or a network
switch in a computer network that serves
as an access point or routing Hub
towards data to destinations outside the
local network so as in the diagram you
can see the definition has been depicted
here now you see the role in netor
communication that is the role of
default gateway in netw communication so
starting with the first role that is
primary function the default gateway
acts as an intermediary that routes the
traffic from a local network to devices
in another Network when a computer sends
data to a device outside it local
network it sends the data to the default
gateway first and then comes the next
role that is Network traffic management
it examines the destinations IP address
of the data and decides if the
destination is within the local network
or outside it if outside the Gateway
forwards the data to the external
network and then comes the next role
that is routing and connectivity in most
Home and Office networks the default
gateway is responsible for connecting
the internal Network to The Wider
internet without a default gateway
computers in a local network can
communicate with each other but cannot
access outside networks now coming to
the next role that is dynamic host
configuration protocol so the default
gateway addresses is often assigned
automatically to individual devices in
the network by DHC
which also assigns IP addresses to these
devices and then comes the Internet
Protocol addressing so the default
gateway has its repeat so the default
gateway has its own unique IP address
which is configured in the network
settings of each device in the network
this address is used to direct outgoing
traffic and receive incoming traffic
from outside the network so these are
the roles of default gateway in network
communication and if we hear a analogy
for better understanding so think of the
default gateway as a post office in a
town if you want to send a letter that
is data packet to someone in another
town that would be the external network
you send it by the post office that will
act as a default gateway here so the
post office knows how to route your
letter to reach the correct destination
and we've seen the roles of default
gateway in network communication so
let's see the importance in network
communication that is efficiency and
order by having a designated route for
external traffic the default gateway
ensures efficient and orderly
communication between Networks and the
next is Network segmentation and
security it can also act as a point of
control and security managing and
monitoring the data entering and leaving
the network so this was about the role
and the advantages of default gateway in
network communication now moving to how
default gateway
works so let's see a scenario so we'll
set up a home network here and we will
have one router and one device that we
will name as computer a and the external
server so here the computer a will act
as a user's personal computer and the
router that will act as the default
gateway and the external server it's a
web server on the internet so now we'll
assign the IP
address for the computer a and the local
IP public IP and subet mask for the
default gateway and the IP address for
the external server so let's start the
communication process between these
devices so if the computer a sends data
to external server so computer a wants
to send data to the external server that
has the IP address 93.1 184.
21634 so computer a checks if the
destination IP is within its local
network using its IP that is
192.168.1.10 and it has a subnet mask as
you can see
255.255.255.0 so the local network range
is from
192.168.1.0 to
192.168.1
255 since 93.1 184. 21634 is outside its
range that is the external server so
computer a sends the data to the default
gateway so the that is the router so the
router handles the data here that is the
default gateway so the router receives
the data from computer a it uses Network
address translation n to translate the
private IP address of computer a to its
public IP that is
2030 .1 13.5 and forwards the data to
the Internet so the router keeps a net
table entry to track this specific data
flow so it knows where to send the
response back so data travels through
the internet and the data packet travels
through various networks and routers in
the internet to reach the external
server that is 93.8 4.21 6.34 so
external server responding we'll see
here so external server processes the
request and sends a response back so the
response is directed to the public IP of
the router here that is
2013.1 3.5 so the router receives and
forwards response so the router will
receive the response and uses its net
table to find the corresponding private
IP of computer a it then forwards the
response to computer a within the local
network and here computer a receives the
response and computer a receives the
response from the router and completes
the communication process so this is the
working of default gateway in a home
network and with this we have come to
the end of this video if you have any
questions related to this video please
ask in the comment section below and our
team of experts will be happy to help
you as soon as possible until then stay
safe and keep learning staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know no
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here